now rob you chose a weapon from our
fortune fire vault that you wanted to
build up against ben
ben you're going to be building this
the irish ring hilted sword
the irish ring sword was a weapon of the
elite gallo glass mercenaries in 12th
century ireland this extremely long
double-edged sword was featured in
season 5 of fortune fire the smiths were
challenged with not only having to forge
out something of this length but also
the added challenge of putting a fuller
in it while both smith struggled to make
such a long blade both light and strong
one smith went too thin in his design
causing a bend in testing and costing
him the competition
your time starts now first step is going
to be to clean up all these pieces i
know i can make this sword i've done it
before
the two bullets are drawn out to the
right length i have them all cleaned up
on the grinder and i'm going to chop
them into five inch sections i end up
with seven layers there is some gapping
between the layers that is a little bit
of a concern i really would like that to
all be nice and tight
now to put the ladder in it
so i end up with 85 layers in my billet
i think that's a high enough layer count
to get a visible ladder pattern
i'd rather double that but i just don't
have time to double that so i figure
80 85
close enough
i finish my thermocycles
it's time to quench
it is absolutely laser straight
and now it's time to start thinking
ahead for
the ring hilt panel do a nice small
pilot hole first
i drill the holes for the tang to fit
through i'm working on grinding the
sword
back to the guard
back to the pommel suddenly i realize
you haven't even started the handle so i
find a piece of poplar it's a relatively
light wood but it's pretty strong i
don't have to worry about going to a
nice fine finish because this handle is
going to get wrapped
nope
i slide on the cross guard
and it's loose
i take the edges
of the slot i hammer them from the top
and i bend them in like this then i take
a squashed pipe i drive that cross guard
all the way down and now i know that
that cross guard isn't going to start
rattling during testing isn't going to
be an issue
i have done projects like this before
over the course of months not over nine
hours
the risk of going more layers is if i
get a bad weld then i have to start over
from scratch i grab my damascus and i
start setting the welds on the press
i have my damascus bars drawn out i need
to divide them up hopefully into five
pieces each and restack them to get a
total of 144 layers i weld them up the
mig welder and put them back in the
forge
so now my main billet is up to
temperature it's 144 layers so i gently
start setting those welds now i'm ready
to do another restack
there are a couple ways to do fullers
one is grind off metal
but i'm worried that i'm not going to
have enough steel
so the other way is to forge them in at
the press
not very straight
it's not great but it is what it is i've
got to move on
all right cross your fingers
in the last round i had a big warp and i
don't want it to be an issue for me
again so this time i want to do
everything i can to avoid warps i did a
good normalization process so i expect
it to be pretty good
it looks pretty darn straight the guards
come in together it has good symmetry
good form i kind of like the way that
the arms sweep up everything's going
great right now
i am frantic i'm scrambling trying to
get everything together to do my glue up
oh no
not good
the edge of the ring is hitting the tang
and i'm unable to lock everything down
if this gives way during the strength
test then things could start to rattle
and come loose so i i'm worried
to fix this i have to grind off some of
that tang so i can get it back on
hopefully before the epoxy said enough
that i can tighten everything down
if i don't get this done it could be a
disaster i mean it'll definitely cost me
the competition i guarantee ben's sword
is going to be tight
five
four three
two
one you guys just finished a nine hour
build well done
when i look over at ben's blade for the
first time it looks good but uh i know
that as good as ben's blade looks what
it's going to come down to is the test
if i can perform well in the test and he
has some kind of problem to test then i
can still come away with the victory
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
dynamic kill test
to find out how lethal your weapons are
i'm going to deliver some deadly blows
on this ballistics dummy and cut some
water tubes
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys
when delivering the cuts over here they
slash nicely to the water tubes and just
demolish that ballistics dummy on that
piece probably ran out of blade as i'm
cutting on the backhand but as you can
see the cuts they are very sharp
overall
it will peel and cut
say so
[Music]
all right
first stop
when i pick this up you can tell there's
a big difference in the weight the edge
is sharp so when i'm chopping into the
butter6 dummy it's a deep cut
but it's heavier and harder to control
it cut the first two tubes and then push
the rest but overall looking at the
damage of the ballistics dummy in some
of the cuts
you will kill
[Music]
all right gentlemen it's time for our
dynamic strength test the bamboo sword
chop and tatami mat slice
i'm not only looking at how well your
weapons hold up in this test but how
they feel and how well they cut
silver's up first
hmm
all right guys right off the blade is
really really light the edges are really
sharp
all in all i think this is a really
well-crafted sword held up very nicely
there's just no damage on this edge
all right
right off
this thing's a destroyer
[Laughter]
it's not outside the realm of proper
weight this is kind of the outside edge
when cutting
you feel the blade slow down as opposed
to just pass through the tatami mat so
it's got a lot of drag on it and that
really has to do with the thickness of
the blade and the style of the grind
that's on this edge
but it held up well it cut good
so good job
all right blaise miss the time has come
to find out if ben you're gonna keep
your unbeaten streak going or if rob
you've dethroned the king and you're
taking home the title of fortune fire
champion and a check for ten thousand
dollars i gotta say this was a very
close race and you made a difficult
decision for the judges today's fortune
fire champion is
ben abbott
ben congratulations you are now 6-0 now
rob you gave him an unbelievable run for
his money but unfortunately your blade
didn't make the cut i'm gonna have to
ask you to please step off the fourth
floor right well thank you i had a great
time thank you so much nice job on that
play dude thank you i'm going to go home
see my family and make a really nice
irish ring-hilted sword it's going to
take me a lot longer than just nine
hours
oh ben
that's 6-0 buddy
you are unbelievable you are yet again
the fortune fire champion
congratulations
i can't believe it i can't believe it
rob is a great smith a really fun guy a
great competitor and i am really happy
to have worked next to him looks like
you're keeping the unbeaten streak alive
congratulations man you're not done yet
we got more of this to go
what did i sign up for good job bud
[Applause]
for those that are coming to to try to
beat me i'm still here still undefeated
bring it on
you